[Music]  et social study but the stars are  posting online Dwayne the rock Johnson  reflects on this priceless moment where  he went undercover with Jimmy Fallon and  brought a fan to tears saying he'll  never forget the special day that  moments like these are the best parts of  faith then there's Mandy Moore's  celebrating her 33rd birthday at  Disneyland with her squad and boyfriend  Taylor goldsmith this is a star and her  beau were spotted wearing nearly  identical outfits matching shirts  jackets and trendy Sonny's it's really  not hard to just love him meanwhile pink  shares a cute pic laughing with her  husband Carey Hart that red this dude is  hot moving on the original America's  Next Top Model judges Nigel Barker Miss  J Alexander and Jay Manuel adorably  reunite quote this trio back together  cat walking on new york city streets can  only mean  one big and chris hemsworth shows off  his impressive surfing skills in  australia  you  [Music]